were you still all in for the taekwondo
team even more
no i'm a huge taekwondo fan my daughter
is actually a black belt at taekwondo
yeah she's right over there that's my
black belt daughter oh my goodness and
so tonight's family night your
daughter's here she's a taekwondo and
and so i used to go to uh i know a lot
of people parents go to uh recitals and
things like that i used to go to
taekwondo competitions with her what i
watched is something beyond anything
i've ever seen before how does your
daughter feel about you being on the
being a judge up there what is the
shiver does she ever comment on you does
she ever critique you at your job yes as
a parent uh of uh well she's now a grown
woman they're asking about you jackie
this is jackie jacqueline schultz he was
asking me how does your daughter feel
about me being a judge do you ever
critique dad for his performance as a
judge no i should yeah give him one
right now i'm judging because my whole
life he's been judging me so i'm used to
it
well but she got into the finals in our
family so
i was i was i went good on you you got
into the finals she's in the top three i
have three children so she's in the top
three
okay i'm gonna make it to the next round
your mother doesn't want to have any
more so i think we're sticking with you
these this is the final
this is the final
i want to talk about what you're wearing
dude your your collar and your glasses i
was like that okay well these are from
the howie mandel collection at sea
you know and a portion of all my glasses
go to uh seth rogen's charity of uh
hilarity for charity
you buy the glasses the suit
the suit is
neil barrett is the shirt and the jacket
is
there you go yeah to me i just walk into
the room and my friend dina puts
they dressed me
[Music]
you weren't a fan of madeline no and you
don't love the taekwondo team no i'm
telling you i'm on the same page as you
i can't sing she's a great singer i was
a huge fan of her um mean tweet songs
yeah you know because as a little quirky
[Applause]
[Music]
i feel bad i'm just i just i'm honest
and then i i feel like bad about because
i know it this means so much to every
person and i think she's a very talented
young lady who has a huge following and
will continue to have a huge following
but in this competition and especially
this season when you look at people like
tae kwon do and jimmy herod who sings i
don't think he got a shot